one of the biggest known stars in
history what was the oldest woman you've
done 78 [__] Nelson I remember
driving all the way from Derby to this
shoe this little old woman's opened the
door and let us in and we've gone to the
producer oh Mike where where's the girl
well you didn't see Eileen when you
walked in we looked at each other
because I'm not doing it I was like come
on we've driven all this way he finished
the scene and he's come running up the
stairs and he started being sick so how
and they're going why it must be really
bad I've gone into a really dark place
now I'm thinking the most disturbing
naughty thoughts mine was like a lead
pipe I've gone through it like a train
they're filming it thinking she can have
a heart attack all of a sudden I'm like
[Music]
the true Geordie podcast